welcome uh all of you uh to the
macmillan center here at yale university
so the macmillan center is yale's
multi-disciplinary multi-school
international convening center for all
kinds of international studies we train
people in languages the histories the
societies
and the politics of lots of different
countries across the world and america's
relationship uh with them we have seven
area studies councils here the largest
of which and i would say one of the most
active of which is the east asian
studies council which is increasingly uh
doing more on korea and then we have
various uh initiatives on a whole slew
of uh different issues including an
environmental issue very relevant to
today's
topic headed by nobel prize winner uh
bill nordhaus
so today
we're going to celebrate the coca-cola
world fund lecture this is a lecture
that was established by the coca-cola
foundation in the early
1990s it's one of the highlights of our
academic
year
we bring in
world leaders
influential
public figures to discuss the world's
most pressing issues and to interact
with faculty and students from across
the yale community
previous lectures include people like
mary robinson the president of ireland
raghu rajan
who was the chief economist at the imf
and then the
head of the reserve bank of india raila
odinga the prime minister of kenya as
well as leading public intellectuals
such as thomas friedman so to introduce
our very distinguished guests today i'd
like to invite up professor juan su kim
who is the chair of
the
east asian studies council our largest
area studies council here at yale
huanci thank you
thank you steve um it's a great honor
to again welcome secretary general ban
ki-moon to yale university
and it's also our pleasure to um welcome
the secretary general's wife um
mrs yu
suntech and
his daughter uh panchayani could you
just briefly raise your hand um
let me see um you first
and then daughter uh
and his son um
yan
[Applause]
and also former u.s ambassador kim sook
here you go
we are especially grateful that our
guests have taken time
out of their really busy schedules uh to
fly all the way from korea to be here
with us today
when i first talked to
the secretary general um via phone i
think last november uh to extend an
invitation
my motive was primarily to raise the
profile of korean studies ideal
the secretary general uh accepted the
invitation without hesitation
but as i hung up the phone i thought
uh oh what have i done
the korean studies program is far too
small to host a figure of such
stature
and thankfully
i was rescued by stephen wilkinson the
director of macmillan center
who enthusiastically
took over the cons the coordination of
such a high profile event
so i'd like to thank steven first and
all the staff
um at the macmillan center as well as
those on the council on east asian
studies who worked very hard to make
today's events possible
at chair of the council in east asian
studies it is my pleasure to introduce
our guest of honor
born in korea mr band received a
bachelor's degree
in international relations from seoul
national university in 1970.
he earned a master's degree in public
administration
from the john f kennedy school of
government at harvard university in
1985.
as all of us know mr bahn served two
consecutive terms as the secretary
general of the united nations
from 2007 to 2016.
throughout his tenure at the un
mr bond stroke to be a breeze builder
to give voice to the world's poorest and
most vulnerable people
and to make the organization more
transparent
and effective
he successfully pressed for action to
combat climate change
an effort that
culminated in the adoption and rapid
entry into the landmark paris agreement
in 2016.
mr bond worked closely with member
states of the un to shape the 2030
agenda for sustainable development
and to establish and women which has
been advancing the organization's work
for gender equality and women's
empowerment
isaban also launched major efforts to
strengthen u.n peace operations
to protect human rights
to improve humanitarian response
to prevent violent extremism
and to revitalize this disarmament
agenda
at the time of his appointment at the
uan mr bahn was a minister of foreign
affairs and trade of the republic of
korea
his 37 years with the ministry included
postings in new delhi washington dc and
vienna and responsibilities for a
variety of portfolio
including foreign policy advisor to the
president
um chief national security advisor to
the president vice minister
deputy minister for policy planning and
director general for american affairs
mrbane has also been actively involved
in issues relating to inner korean
relations
by serving as chairman of the
preparatory commission for the
comprehensive
nuclear test span treaty organization
after he finishes two terms
as the uan secretary general mr bond
served as the chairman of presidential
national council on climate and air
quality
from 19 2019 to 2021.
in 2018 he was elected as the chairman
of baal forum for asia
mr ban along with former president of
austria mr heinz fisher
was inducted as a co-chair
of the ban guimon center for global
citizens in vienna austria
isaban is the chair of the global center
for adaptation
an international organization hosted by
the netherlands
he was also elected as chairman of ioc
ethics committee in september 2017.
isabel served as the honorary chairman
at the institute of global engagement
and empowerment
as
at yonsei university in korea from 2018
to um this year
in february 2018
he was elected and has been serving as
the president of the assembly and chair
of the council of global green growth
institute
currently he is the chairman of panjimun
foundation for a better future and
distinguished chair professor and
honorary chairman of the future strategy
institute at seoul national university
so mr van current
current
efforts reside in addressing
the major global
struggles of climate change the pandemic
and sustainable development
so what is past the most international
perspective conceivable
mr bhan will be speaking on these
pressing issues today
so without further ado
please join me in welcoming our
distinguished speaker
secretary-general ban ki-moon
[Applause]
hmm
thank you
professor stephen wilkinson
director of
mcmillan center
and professor kim ansu
chair of the
asian studies
council
thank you for your very warm
introduction
i'm incredibly honored to follow
the footsteps of many lumina
illuminae and luminaries
and delivered this coca-cola world fund
at the yale university
dear students
and faculty members ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much again for your very
kind introduction in fact you have
preempted most of the topics which i was
going to say
so
i don't know how much i can add to this
again in any way it's a great honor for
me to be with you this
today
and try to discuss
and share first of all my vision and my
experience
and
try to discuss this matter with you
i was given about the 45 minutes
i hope this 45 minutes will not make you
any anybody sleep
because it may i hope it will not make
you
a little bit
tired
i'd like to
speak about
what's the kovid 19 pandemic
and climate change
and
carbon neutrality and global citizens
after my lecture
i will open up the floor for
some questions which you may have
i'm sorry that for my voice has
i've been speaking all day long since
yesterday so this is my last occasion
since during last one week so i hope you
will understand my
condition
indeed
i have wonderful memories of my
april
16 visit
to this very distinguished university
where
under my initiative united nations has
been convening
sort of a colloquium of university
presence
while dealing with all climate change
and other global agendas we just wanted
to have wisdoms
and
some
advices from university academic
institutions so
yale university president salovey was
one of the six
presidents on whom
we really
depended upon their
guidance and wisdom and academic
intellectual
knowledges
on climate change
and human rights
and sustainable development
and women's empowerment and all the
global agendas united nations were
handling and hoping
to achieve in their regard
i met the president sullivan
this morning a little bit and expressed
my deepest thanks again after many years
after my retirement and again i thank
you very much
i hope our discussions today will also
help me even though i'm
a private citizen
as well
introduced i'm holding at least
more than a thousand
thousand international positions
so
you can use my
voice if you have anything i have a lot
of
avenues and way to deliver and raise the
problems of our global problems to the
public and global leaders
now six years later
as a
due
senseless war of aggression
in
ukraine
has been killing civilians forcing
millions of ukrainian citizens
according to unesco
[Music]
resulting in the damage and destruction
of at least
53
cultural sites in ukraine since the
russian
invasion began i feel my words of
at yale university
and i have been speaking loud and
clearly
and in my capacity as the vice chairman
of the elders
on organization private organization
founded by nelson mandela
and composed of just 10
global leaders former presidents and
nobel peace laureates and i'm working as
the vice chairman of that and we have
strongly condemned
this illegal and unacceptable aggression
of ukraine so this is a part of
the configurations but
it has
it is now
affecting all spectrums of our life
including peace and security
and development and human rights
dear students and faculty members
today
we find ourselves at the center of
variety of converging
crises and increased uncertainty
the ongoing confident 19 pandemic
continues to append our economies
societies and way of life
great power tensions
are surging
an ongoing conflict in ukraine
represents
one of the most
dangerous moments for global security in
decades
with profound humanitarian and economic
repercussions at the same time
our planet is on fire
literally and figuratively
with the climate crisis deepening
as global temperatures are rising
flood range
and wildfires burn
copper 19 and other global crisis
such as climate change have underlined
our fundamental interconnectedness
no country is an island
nobody is free
from these
global threats
they have also made it clear that we
need
global solutions
born out of cooperation and partnership
and sustainability to address the global
challenges that we face
no country however powerful and
resourceful
like just like united states
can solve these
these challenges alone
we need to
forge a stronger
tripartite
partnership
that means government business
communities and civil society maybe you
may belong to civil society now but some
of you will be joining government and
businesses therefore this
tripartite partnership is the most
important
to make sure that our society becomes
sustainable sustainable
i believe that corporate 19 has also
offered us a glimpse of the global
disruptions
that will arise from climate change
in the
near future
these include
elevated public health perils
mass
displacement
turmoil to supply chains
and increase conflict
and protracted economic crisis
both pandemics and climate change are
global issues which require a strong
multilateral response
and international cooperation and
partnership as i have stated
on the this spectrum
of covenant 19
planetary crisis conflict and teasing
changes
we have also made progress in key areas
and i know that we have
vital opportunities to change the world
for the better
that is why i have established punjab
foundation for a better future this is a
small foundation this is
the only personal foundation which i
have founded
but i'm just working
to make
even small contribution
to make our future better
better for all
but to do so
again we must come together
in solidarity
and to beat coveted 19
and urgently take climate actions
we must redouble our efforts
to live up to the guiding ideals of the
united nations charter
and it's a pledge
to i quote
save the succeeding generations
from the scourge of war on court
this is the first line
when
our forefathers
established united nations and this is
the first line of the united nations why
they were committed
after second world war to establish the
united nations
we must enhance
protection of civilians during wars
as well as the refugees that
those wars
make
we must strive to better emphasize
prevention
as a mechanism to address armed conflict
and suffering
and we must go further
in bolstering international justice and
accountability
in the face of war crimes
dear students ladies and gentlemen
i'd like to begin by providing you with
a bit of an overview
on the wide-ranging wide-ranging global
disruptions and impacts of this global
global pandemic
now into is a third year
coveted 19 pandemic
continues to alter
our personal lives communities
and the world itself
with the nearly
515 million
global cases
and at least
6.2 million
tragic global deaths
this pandemic has caused immense
suffering and serious challenges all
around the
the richest and biggest country united
states
also had
81.4 million cases and almost 1 million
deaths
coffee 19 has
precipitated oversized impact
on global economic growth and pronounced
supply and demand side disruptions
such supply chain issues are now
worsening because of the crisis in
ukraine
covenant 19 has also amplified existing
inequalities
in health
labor
housing
food
gender
and other key areas
these impacts alongside
rising inflation
have converged to create the most
significant global social economic
crisis
since the great depression
for example
the united nations estimates the kovil
19
cost
225 million
full-time jobs
in the year 2020 alone
the global network
against the food crisis
says that the number of food insecure
people is now at 155
million persons
of five year high
as a result of the pandemic
and unicef wants the one third
of the world's children
are unable to access
remote learning during school closures
under this traveling backdrop of the
global development landscape
it is clear that
ongoing recovery will be both extended
and urges
and this is particularly true as vaccine
and therapeutic
inequity continues to extend
the pandemic for so many all around the
world
particularly
those in developing countries
to ensure that we recover correctly it
is not enough to build back
we must build back better
as well as greener
currently as you may know i'm serving
as president of the assembly
of an international organization called
global green growth institute
which is headquartered in korea with the
43
member states
indeed our recovery
from coveted 19 must
simultaneously address
climate action
climate action climate change and kobe
19 are the two sides of one coin it is
tightly
connected
we have to understand this connected
interconnectedness between all the
global
global challenges
doing so will go a long way in helping
to guide us
towards a more sustainable and resilient
carbon neutral
for all people
and our planet
with this in mind i firmly believe
that
the international community must
actively scale up
global leadership and cooperation
in the sphere of public health
we must also expand
preparedness
in anticipation of both the next waves
and next pandemics
modern pandemics are increasingly
interrelated
to biodiversity loss
and closer interaction
between humans and animals
i came to new york and here yesterday
from my visit
to
colombia
colombia is one of the
rich biodiversity country i think they
are the second only to
to brazil
i flew over
this
40 street deep forestry
and
just one national park one national park
should be taken
i was surprised to find out first of all
the size of this national park
i was told that there are 62
such parks
with the forestry
the size of one park
was half of south korea
i was just stunned
while i was very much impressed
by the huge forestry
but i was also sad
to have seen so many areas
deforestated deforestated
this is very sad this will really cause
climate
temperature rising
in any way
the fact
of the matter which we are now
confused
addressing remains that the global
responses
has been too slow
and too weak
this is the most pressing task ahead of
us
i'm afraid to tell you that
young generation students like you will
soon be in charge to address this issue
if
my generation
and generation of
professors are not doing enough
then i think it will fall on your
shoulders
it can set also the stage for a more
secure
insecure
international order
in the post-pandemic era
so it has also something to do with
conflict political conflict
thankfully
a variety of safe and effective vaccines
and other measures are being distributed
around the world
this is incredibly
encouraging
with over
11 billion total vaccine doses
administered to date
coupled with a continuation of proactive
measures such as
testing
masking
ventilations
therapeutics vaccines represent the
global community's best hope
of ending this pandemic
but at the moment
only about
66 percent
of the global population
mostly those in wealthy nations
have received just one jab of coveted 19
vaccine
i have got four vaccine jobs
i think most of you i was told that
professor wilkinson you had professor
kim
three okay
i'm better than you
but
in any way
if you go to africa just 16
16
all covering african people they have
just one
one japs one vaccine this is a reality
this is a both shameful
and counterproductive as we strive to
sustain sustainably
persevere over this pandemic and return
to semblance of normality
indeed global leaders
have a moral and humanitarian obligation
to rectify
the current situation of a growth
vaccine and treatment inequality and
injustice
we need to urgently
come together in solidarity
to vaccinate the world and end this
pandemic
and we must remember
no one is safe
until everybody is safe
that's a fact
if your family member or if one of your
friends
is
infected
then you are old
you can easily be affected therefore
inmate must make sure that everybody
should be safe
with this in mind
all nations
should
enhance support for the u.n coverage
mechanism in its mission to get vaccines
to those in need
it is wonderful
that the countries
like the united states
and europe
see
some hope
as the virus becomes endemic yet largely
treatable
with vaccines and therapeutics
but we must remember
that
this virus remains
formidable enemy
and not to let our guards down
especially as much as
of the world remains
unprotected with this in mind again i
reiterate the un secretary general
antonio cuterich's appeal
for a global vaccination plan to double
production
and reach at least 70 percent of the
world's population
by mid-2022
just two months
we have both the resources
and ability to do so but
lack the political will
i have found during my tenure
service at the united nations
it is just because of lack of political
will
the political leaders do not
have such a firm determined will
if they show
some determination then i think we can
handle this matter much much earlier and
easily
dear students and professors let me just
now go back to
the origin of the problems that is
climate change phenomena
you must have heard many times that
since the industrialization about 200
years ago
humanity has achieved remarkable
economic growth and technological
progress
however
in the process
serious
environmental damage
occurred
and global warming and climate change
has ensued as a result of reckless
human-made carbon emissions
as biodiversity and habitats are
destroyed due to environmental
destruction
wild animals
have increasingly become into contact
with the humans and as a result
normal viruses and pandemic have spread
indeed nearly
all of the
viruses that have emerged in the 21st
century
from south in 2000 to copyright 19
recently share the characteristics of
being
common infectious diseases between
humans and animals
the degradation of our ecosystem by
human beings in the name of development
i think we have
become
very close
to animals
that's the main reason why we are
suffering from now
in 2021 alone
historic reign
dramatically detached
central china
and in the mediterranean
has been in flames
with the terrifying wildfires
burning in greece turkey africa i think
the western coast of united states has
also suffered a lot because of these
wildfires
the catastrophic flooding
submerged parts of central europe
like
germany
belgium underwater last september
last summer
i was told that the flood which
devastated some part of
germany
was first such first one in 1 000 years
1 000 years you may you may not believe
it
but it's a
science
which
who had
determined that it was the worst case in
1 000 years in germany in such a
prosperous and wealthy countries
the five hottest years
of globally recorded temperatures
have now all occurred
since 2015 during last seven years july
2021 last year
was the earth hottest month
ever recorded
the fifth
extinction people say that may
the sixth extinction may occur
in 100 years if when we do not take
origin action
then when this fifth mass extinction
happened
what does this
mass extinction means
65 million years ago
most of the animals including
dinosaur
just perished
65 million years ago
then why we have to
suffer from this sixth mass extinction
in just 100 years
this is not my warning
this is the warning of a scientist and
climatologist and geologist geologist
so we have to make sure that within
within 100 years
i think we may not be here at that time
but some of your
grandparents and grand
great grandparents i mean
sons
daughters will suffer from this mass
extinction
geologists say that mass extinction
means that at least 70 percent of all
species
will perish
when it happens
we have to really do much much more to
prevent
this kind of a mass extinction from
happening
here in the united states you know very
well
the realities of rapidly accelerating
climate crisis
summers are getting both longer and
hotter
and the frequency and intensity of
flooding
storms and heavy heat waves is
increasing
each and every year
overwhelming is not just a future threat
a landmark study released recently in
the scientific journal
the nature
says that nearly
37 percent
of all global heat related deaths
can now be blamed on human-caused
climate change
how can you mitigate
these dire threats
western nations such as the united
nations united states united kingdom of
european union
certainly cannot do it alone
nor can asian countries korea japan
china can do it alone
what is needed
is an unprecedented
global effort propelled by
multilateralism
solidarity and partnership
at least in our common efforts we lost
to four years at least four years
during the time
of trump or demonstration i'm not here
to criticize any
any nations
when i was a secretary general at the
united nations
i was very careful
not to directly
confront any member state of head of
state now i'm a private citizen
i have been speaking out quite
frequently
that president trump's decision to
withdraw
from the paris climate change agreement
was first of all
politically very society
and economically
very irresponsible
scientifically speaking
dead wrong
and i want that
his name
will be
remaining in the wrong side of history
i have been speaking out
how much time and energy and passion
and difficulties and challenges i have
experienced during 10 years
to make sure that
climate change would be agreement
you do not understand how difficult it
has been
195 state parties signed
but this is
almost unprecedented way of decision
making
normally you make decision by majority
or two-thirds majority or you can go
three-quarter majority but normally
two-thirds majority
is
most difficult process
but this is
100
absolute unanimity
even a single country
could kill
the decision
that might have happened
in reality at the last minute of the
gambling
i thought that everything was ready
everybody was ready but there was only
one country just
who was indicating that they they would
not support it there was a big crisis
john kerry myself angela angel america
or everybody went to that delegation
really wanted to if we can break the
neck
but lastly
through some subtle
between myself and
the party concerned
we were able to
finally adapt this
agreement
and i made sure that it came into effect
before i leave the united nations
it was just a matter of
one and a half a month one and a half a
month
my term ended
just one and a half months later
after this
paris climate change became effective
it is a law
it's a treaty
two months later
as soon as when president trump came
he just withdrew
but fortunately just u.s withdrawal
didn't affect
the existence and effectiveness of this
agreement
had it not been effective
and trump
withdrew from this
then we would not have climate change
agreement even now
it might have been very very
difficult moment and
when
president biden biden
just joined as his first presidential
act to rejoin the paris parish climate
change agreement i really had the sigh
of deep relief
this is
real
real story i'm telling you from my own
experience in any way ladies and
gentlemen
i still believe that paris agreement
offers us
our best hope
to persevere of the serious threat
to our planet
but
we must urgently step up
implementing
commitment
we don't have a planet b
because
we
we don't have a plan b
we have only plan a
because we don't have another planet b
this is something
which i have been repeatedly saying
you may quote this one
i don't claim any
any you know
copyright or whatever
ladies and gentlemen we have no time to
lose
disordering ipcc report
released in march
this year
express explicitly concludes by warning
that
i put
any further delay
in concerted anticipatory global action
on adaptation and mitigation
will miss a brief and rapidly closing
window of opportunity
to secure a livable
and sustainable future for all on court
this is what
the ipcc composed of more than 2 000
scientists climatologist
has been repeatedly warning
so we must listen
to the voices of scientists
doing so will be the difference between
either
charting
a secure and prosperous future proceed
for students such as yourselves and our
next generation
if we do not do that
we will embark on a future
that condemns
young people and their children
to a planet besieged by
flames
heat and flood
what happens is up to us
but i'm again saying that we must act
now
with this in mind
in order to faithfully implement the
paris agreement
and push it even further
all stakeholders need to expand
their actions to cut emissions
and expect
the rapid
decarbonization of the global economy to
achieve carbon neutrality
fortunately many countries including the
united states european union
republic of korea japan
i think they have announced carbon
neutrality 2050.
china has announced carbon neutrality 26
india
has announced 2017.
that
i am very much
disappointed
world leaders have understood the
chinese
committee commitment by 2016
was accepted accepted understood
understood but when
china india said 2017
that has really shaken and
destroyed
full commitment
during carbon
i mean during cup 26 in classroom last
year
our target was that
by the middle of
by the end of 2050
this carbon neutrality should be
committed then because of india
and
because just one as i said one country
can kill all this agreement
there was no other way but to agree by
saying by saying that
by and
around the middle of the century
not by this
not by 2015 so it was a little bit
watered down
and there was no agreement for financial
contribution by the rich countries
i am deeply concerned and deeply
disappointed that united states and
european union they have not kept their
promise which they made publicly in 2009
just
how many years 13 years has passed
they had they promised that they would
provide 100 billion dollars every year
by 2020 then by this time
100 billion dollars should be ready to
be distributed to developing countries
now
but even
just 13 years after
they are not still keeping their
promises
this is the lack of political will
what i have been always criticizing
publicly to the member state
and
i am again urging
that big countries which countries
first united states and european union
japan
and including korea too
they have provide mobilize at least 100
billion dollars every year
so ladies and gentlemen what i'm just
trying to say is that we have to do all
what we have to do
you may feel that
you know i don't understand or i don't
have any responsibility but i think
there are some ways
which you can help at this time
you may quote me
you may quote ipcc but you may raise
your voices
to your governors to your senators
and parliamentarians
and your president
then tell them that
please make sure that this is the world
where i and my
parents and my
my sons and daughters will live so just
make sure that during your time
keep this promise which you have made
carbon neutrality by 2050
i think this you have such a power and
raise your voice
you you see that my voice is already
very much you know down
because i have been always speaking out
like this way with the passion
by the end of the day
i'm almost losing my
my voice
i have been speaking all the times like
this way
speaking out to the world leaders
now i'm relying
on your power
you have the vote
if they are not committed you can change
the candidate you can change the present
this is your prerogative as a citizens
of the world
again i'm really asking
we simply must adapt and act now
or perish later
do you want to be perished
leaders must elevate their political
will
for climate action
and industries
and businesses
must act in partnership and leading
educational institutions
such as yale university and young people
like yourselves
have a critical role to play
in this
in this regard
we need
on all hands on the tech approach
now the single person is
ex
exempt from this
you may
you may think that i'm just a student
but you have the voting right you have
the voice again
and you the younger generation
are the future leaders
and global citizens
that i firmly believe
can lead us to a brighter and more
sustainable and more future more
inclusive future
ladies and gentlemen let me just think
tell you as i conclude about global
citizenship
i have been meeting so many world
leaders
they all
claim that i'm the leader
but i have not seen
among them
not many
truly
genuinely
global leaders
with global citizens at best
they are the national leaders
what does that mean then global
citizenship
global citizens
means that
those who identify themselves
not merely as a member of the community
but
citizen of the world
the passport you you may carry your
nationality
does not mean much at this time
with the transformative
development of communication
transportation
information
science and technology
i think we are living in a very small
small world
whatever i'm speaking now
can be delivered to the corner of the
end of the world
within a fraction of a second
therefore we are all
living in a very small world we are all
global citizens
when i was 18 years old boy
i was very lucky lucky boy at that time
to have been invited to white house and
met president kennedy john f kennedy
i was not even
able to meet
the mayor of my own
city
young boy
i was one of 140
global students
what president kennedy said
the politicians
political leaders do not engage each
other of course it was true during the
height of cold war
khrushchev and kennedy were not talking
each other they were fighting
the national borders
do not mean much
national borders meant much at that time
there was a [ __ ] up
restrictions
so you could not go from this country to
another without passport or whatever
particularly for koreans
when we
were belonging to
this
free democratic society we're not
allowed to visit any communist country
but what he said
you young people
can do much better
the pro the question was
whether
you are ready to extend your helping
hand
that was inspiring
quite inspiring i thought
at that time i was thinking what should
i do
if i said that i wanted to become the
secretary general that's a lie
i thought what should i do for my
country
korea was very poor at the time
just a few years after korean war
so i thought that i should do something
for my country the reconstruction and
development of my country
that's why i became secretary general
and
40 minutes of korea later
when i became 40 minutes of united korea
i was thinking and my eyes were opening
wider than
before
then i was thinking what could i do for
the world now
that's my
confession
if i had such ambition from young
that to become secretary general of the
united nations that's not
but i think for you now
you may have some limited the future
dreams but you can
be practical but you can have a better
visions
but what is important at this time have
some global vision
and global citizenship in your in your
in your heart
then when you act as a global citizen
i'm sure that you'll make much much more
and better contribution to address all
these global challenges
this is my message today to you and i
sincerely hope that we all work together
to make this world better
we cannot just live this way to our
succeeding generation
you may think that you you are not
responsible but at least you have a
moral responsibility as i am now
i don't have any political
responsibility now
but i have a moral responsibility you
also
do have moral responsibility to work
together
in solidarity in partnership
to make this world sustainable and more
peaceful
and prosperous
that's your moral responsibility and
let us try to make this world a better
form
thank you very much and for your
attention thank you
everyone we'll take questions from the
audience if you could just raise your
hand so we can bring you the mic
good evening
[Music]
uh mr ban thank you first of all uh so
much for this talk and for your efforts
to make our our world better my name is
i am fox international fellow here at
yale and as you spoke about the global
citizenship i consider myself as a
global citizen at least because this
fellowship considers
us
folks fellows as
citizen ambassadors and
i study
diplomacy and international relations
for 10 years and i consider
communication as the essence of
diplomacy and as you spoke about
the race of our voice um
i as young woman who intends to join the
united nations
i'm wondering
how can i
make this voice heard because
one thing is to raise
voice and the other other thing is to be
heard thank you
there are many many ways you know for
your children or yourself to contribute
to
a current world and i welcome
i welcome anybody who really want to
be
you know working for the united nations
i think
united nations is the most universal
and global organization so for any young
young talented people would be most
welcome but there are certain procedures
and regulations so i think i hope
you can just
make sure that
all this
first of all prepare for all these you
know
examination whatever test
then
opportunities are always open
but
there are many uh
students while
while i was serving who really wanted to
start from internship internship
this is also competitive quite
competitive
[Music]
the un
selects at least 900
uh 1200
interns every year
uh three-month internship and there are
many ways and many organizations are
opening
these positions
un positions are always
open to the world it's not only limited
to a u.n staff
whenever there is opening therefore i
think your
[Music]
friends or whoever maybe can have an
opportunity
but you must be prepared for that
i hope that i have addressed
to your question
thank you so much secretary general
my name is mary evelyn tucker i teach at
the school of the environment in the
divinity school
and i would be so grateful if you would
comment on the event that took place at
the united nations
when the pope came to speak
and also his encyclical laudato c
on the environment which is also calling
people to a global citizenship but an
integral ecology that brings people and
the planet uh together so i'd love to
have your comment
on that and thank you so much for your
talk
so is your question or comment
the ques the question is
uh laudato c
is one of the most important documents
in bringing a moral force
together for the environment
uh many people feel it's unprecedented
and i wanted to have your comment on the
pope's both his speech at the united
nations but also the encyclical which he
wrote to affect the paris agreement in
december of 2015.
i think
as of now
paris climate change sets
very walkable
and most
not i don't think it is most ambitious
but it's a workable path
to address climate change
and
there are many
many ways we can
further strengthen
and strengthened based on this paris
climate change agreement
even
reaching to this agreement
had to make many
concessions and
some
some of
some
so all negotiation for example all
negotiations are not perfect one perfect
one i don't think the paris agreement is
a perfect one even with imperfect one
people are not implementing as i said
if we do
all
what is said
in the paris agreement i think we can at
least
prevent
such catastrophic
consequences
but even including united states are not
keeping all
to his
commitment faithfully
for example
one
one thing really disappointed me
recently
is only natural and absolutely right
and necessary
we provide humanitarian assistance to
people of ukrainian they deserve our
support
but that does not mean that
this money
for humanitarian support are slashed
from
climate fundings
climate funds
u.s
has promised 11 at least 11
billion dollars a year
for climate
out of 100 billion dollars
then president biden just cut 10 billion
dollars out of 11 and sent to ukraine
first
of course saving lives may be much more
urgent
but saving our planet is also urgent
many european countries are now slashing
such fundings from
climate
climate fundings
that is what i have been speaking out
and criticizing
through my op-ed or my speeches
this is short-sightedness
so don't blame that
parish climate change may not be
the perfect one there is no such perfect
constitution perfect laws this is all
out of um
out of a negotiation
we could have been much much more
ambitious
much much tougher
but that was all
i could have done
even do you know how how many years
has it taken
from since
1992 kyoto protocol
2015 it almost took 30 years
30 years
1992 kyoto protocol
was the result out of
almost a ten years negotiations
then total protocol became almost
useless
useless because
u.s
did not
join u.s signed it
but was not directified by the
parliament a senate
so when
al gore as a vice president he proudly
signed it but it became useless for the
united united states
and that means when u.s didn't join
then total proof to
become almost a death
from the moment it became
became effective
so there was a lot of such frustrating
processes and that's why as soon as i
became secretary general i made it
number one top priority and i first
tried to convince president bush at that
time
he was not convinced
but at the end he was convinced
he was convinced
and i was very much grateful to him
because
he just added his voice
reluctantly
then made the beginning
beginning of success
since he said yes
then it took nine years
from 2007
then 2000 until
2015.
as i said i don't know you know i felt
how much i was lucky
because
that was adopted before trump came in
if
trump joined
this presidency all a little earlier i
don't think we we have even now we don't
have
this climate agreement yeah again there
is no such perfect one here
yeah
the previous question so
the catholic church has more than one
million
members around the world and
one million one billion one billion so
do you think there's any role the the
catholic pope can play
to really enforce this paris
environmental agreement
the religious leaders have a very
important role to play
and i am
deeply grateful
to pope francis
in making sure that
one billion
catholic
catholic believers i mean church wars
he instructed
and i discussed this method with the
pope himself
in at the united nations as well as
in rome vatican i visit vatican two
three times to
make sure that
catholic community would join
and he issued his degree to all one
billion
catholics
that really helped a lot that really
helped a lot i forgot the name of this
decree but in any way
after that i went to
vatican after my retirement i think
ambassador kim
he was
with me
to pay my great thanks to to him
then another
contribution he made
was
he came to the united nations twice
according to all history of the united
nations
all the popes previous popes
they came
just once
in their
proper leadership
once to the united nations
then
current pope francis
is the only exception he came twice
to urge member state
to agree on social development and to
agree on
climate change
he gave such
full blessings
full blessings of course he is not a
politician so he could not
exert the political pressure but he has
given his
full blessings i think i'm still very
much grateful for his
intervention yeah thank you
yes
uh hello mr ben uh thank you so much for
coming here my name is eli and i'm a
second year mba student of yale school
of management
first thing
i do feel much better at the private
season after hearing your speech at
least i can say something
if i feel something's wrong
and i feel your pain as a secretary of
general of the united nations that
you need to
try our best to keep everybody's
standard stand together
second i do have a question for your
forward-looking plan as the president of
the pangimon foundation do you have any
plans to continue the carbon
neutralization initiative
for the next step
so what do you want about fun given
foundation
so for the next step
do you have any plans or do you want to
share any thoughts that how do you want
to utilize this platform
i should confess that this abundant
foundation was established just three
years ago
[Music]
with some
humble
humble
commitment
that i should do whatever i can
to make
our future better
for everyone
this is a small foundation composed of
some small group of
people but i have a limited capacity in
doing but
i am using
my role
as a former secretary general
my moral voice
working in close
cooperation and association with the
other
other organizations and governments
i
i was when i was introduced by professor
kim
i'm now holding many
different positions
for example
when it comes to climate
i am chairman of global
center
on adaptation
adaptation
there are two policy map policy
responses to climate one is
mitigation and adaptation
mitigation we know that we have to
mitigate we have to reduce carbon
carbon emissions
but how to invest wisely
for the future to prevent any
future
disruptive
climate
consequences that is adaptation
for example
when you
build buildings infrastructures when you
build the
street i mean
roads
or
when you plant some
crops
then how can you
solve this
climate resilient crops
or how can you build
climate resilient buildings and
infrastructures
there are many ways
we can save
money
from future possible destruction
caused by climate
those are the
much much more
i mean better ideas
i'm working as a chairman of this one
and as i said i'm working also as a
chairman of this global green growth
institute
and i'm also working in other other i'm
using
all different different organizations
i'm also working as a chairman of this
banking center for global citizens
global citizenship
we don't have any tools or resources
like you build a house or whatever
but we teach them
what needs to be done
to prevent further destructive
disruptive consequences caused by
climate change and we also
just tried to urge world leaders to
empower women
empower
youth protect the human rights
and do much more on climate issues and
make a sustainable sustainable
development essentially spectrum
i'm using my
voice
as a former secretary general these are
something which i am doing
so if you add your voices and i will
have the i'll be much much
have a stronger voice as stronger as
microphones uh so to say thank you very
much thank you yeah
one more question and then
uh we prepared the reception on the
second floor so all of you are welcome
to join and keep asking secretary more
questions okay one more question once
you do you want to pick the last
question
somebody
the most difficult decision to make
okay you and um you maybe you can expect
your two questions and maybe uh
secretary general can answer together
uh thank you secretary general for your
speech i'm chris a undergraduate student
from south korea
um i think i speak for everyone in this
room and i say you're
a symbol of collaboration for worldwide
collaboration and global collaboration
the kovin 19 pandemic has changed our
individual lives but in addition we've
seen that it requires us to work
together and to wear masks to get
vaccinated to be aware of
this spreading the disease to others i
see all of these as acts of
collaboration have you seen
any instances where the pandemic has
changed collaboration on the global
level
and
has it affected
collaboration between countries
so
so you're now talking about all these
vaccine vaccine issues now
i
i i have not been engaged in this
negotiation since i'm out of the united
nations but during my time
[Music]
i whenever such kind of
global health problems happened
of course you know
i had to work very close with the who
who is the main organization
which deals with all these global health
issues
but who
frankly speaking
is a very small organization among
16
specialized agencies there are bigger
organizations but they are mostly
research organization and doesn't have
operational capacities
so that's why
from the beginning
there was some
problems in addressing
pandemic issues
i immediately thought that
the wh
you may know president trump has been
criticizing
wh
then
then maybe
half right half wrong but
one
why i am critical is that
president trump was wrong in withdrawing
instead of supporting the who
whatever
mistakes
or
some mishandling at the beginning there
may be
u.s should have given
much bigger
and stronger support for who
rather than just withdrawing and cutting
funding then the rich couldn't have any
any role to play
then i telephoned to
as a former secretary general i
telephoned dr ted ross wh director
general
look
this is not
this is going to be a very serious issue
i telephoned in march 2020
march 20
you better walk
and consult with the secretary of the
united nations and mobilize
mobilize a whole united nations
organization
only secretary general can mobilize all
not the director general of who if the
u.s
intervened from the beginning
i think u.s could
mobilize such a global rule
that's the u.s president and secretary
general of the united nations
i think there are two who can
mobilize
global resources
but he didn't
and president trump withdrew
just a couple of fundings
that's the beginning of the worst
worst things happening now
i already won the from the beginning now
looking back
i think we must learn all these lessons
from
failures
we failed in fact
we could have prevented in much much
quicker
much more effective way
and
i think i said that this is an issue of
justice
justice
just vaccinating american people didn't
mean much
because
viruses do not care about
the borders people have been you know
traveling
at the beginning at the beginning and
therefore we have learning if you do not
learn from the past failure
you are apt to repeat the same things
in 2014
when ebola broke out in west africa
the united nations just took one day
to make a decision
while
coronavirus case
it took four months
there was a big difference from one day
to four months
security council i reported to the
security council look
this ebola
which is now shipping through western
africa
is not
a normal one
we must take urgent action mobilize all
the resources
the security council
the worst reason why security council is
involved in these health issues because
health can create a lot of global
security issues like um coffee 19 has
been doing
then security council adopted urgent
resolution by one day
that ebola
is
a serious threat to international peace
and security
of course they mentioned health issues
what is the issue of
peace and security
we organized
ebola mission ebola mission
united states
sent 7 000 soldiers military soldiers
french
500 united kingdom 750 soldiers they
were all dispatched immediately to
western africa they blockaded all
borders
then there are not much traffic among
these infected areas and i myself
risked my life
to visit the areas
i was quarantined 21 days after
returning
but united nations and world bank didn't
do anything
not much
this is a main reason because
security council because of the conflict
between united states and china
china
boycotted
it took four months to declare
that
kovid 19
is a serious threat to international
peace and security after four months
most of the countries have been
devastated
just within four months if there was an
urgent
urgent action
blocking somewhere
and if
your countries really collaborate with
each other
so this kind of
sign of
cyano-american conflict even affected
are global health issues
so this is quite regrettable so we have
to learn
all these hard lessons not to repeat
not to repeat in the future
yeah i hope the later learned from this
two year long pandemic
like uh period um
anyway
maybe i would give you the honor to ask
him in person on the second floor how
did it sound
okay thank you so much thank you so much
secretary general for your wonderful
talk please skip around the floor
thank you
[Music]
you